hello everyone and welcome to the last
round of the London chess classic when
Michael Adams lost against Magnus
Carlsen he said in an interview with
Maurice that he has a bad score against
every player in this tournament but this
actually isn't the case when playing
against Caruana
so far until this game the result was
five wins each and six draws so it was a
equal and that this game will will
proclaim the winner of their mutual
encounters so let's see this game
Fabiano has the white pieces and he has
to win this game to tie with neppo and
go into the tiebreaks he plays c4 so an
English opening against the Englishman
Michael Adams Knight to f6 Knight to c3
we have E 5 the two knights variation
Knight to f3 and Knight to c6 the four
Knights variation of the English opening
g3 d5 seek after Sun d5 Knight captures
on d5 and Bishop to g2 and here both
could capture Knight chapter since e3
and after B captures played Bishop to c5
and this is this is perfectly fine for
black but Adams decides to go for Bishop
to c5 immediately karana castles Adams
castles and d3 now rook to e8 and Knight
to g5 now opening up a discovered attack
on this night and maybe maybe due to
this it was better to capture on c3
immediately so ok Knight back to f6 and
Queen to b3 already this is move 10
Caruana has a queen on b3 knight on d5
and threatening the unprotected f7 pawn
Queen to e7 and like rook to e8 probably
would have been better but this is
always hard when you play a rook to e8
admit that it was a mistake and played
back to f8 but ok maybe this is a line
maybe Queen e7 is is better so Queen to
e7 Knight to d5 now would attempt on the
Queen Knight captures Queen Bishop
captures and now the Bishop Queen and
the knight are attacking f7 Knight to d8
now Knight is defending the F pawn as
well and here Queen to c4
an interesting line would be nice to e4
attacking the dark square bishop and
after night to e6 Knight captures Knight
captures and queen to a3 and after
Bishop to h3 rook to e1 c6 and Bishop to
c4 and it's a it's a pretty different
game that than what players decided to
go for but still an equal an equal game
so after night to d8 Khurana chose Queen
to c4 probably to try and win this he
needs the win this game
Bishop to d4 now and the bishop to d4 is
actually a great square for the bishop
an interesting line here would be to
play III kind of you attack the bishop
but then again your bishop on c1 isn't
protecting the night and g5 but after a
Bishop to b6 Queen to h4 now attacking
h7 h6 night to f3 and now Queen captures
Knight captures and c6 and black is
black is solid here there is there is
nothing for for white to look for in
this position so after Bishop to d4
Bishop back to G to buy Caruana first h6
Knight to f3 and Knight to c6 Bishop to
e3 and now Caruana allows Adams to
triple his pawns and Adams does this
Bishop captures f captures and now e4 of
course karana could capture upon with
the queen but then he's going into an
endgame with triple the Triple D pawns
so d captures on e4 and now a5 and
before I forget I wanted to say this in
the beginning this game actually lasted
for 6 hours so six hours they you know
battled it out a three and rook to a6
preparing rook b6 to go for the b2 pawn
rook 8 2 c1
now rugby 6 I roped the c2 defending the
pawn and Bishop to e6 or the temple on
the Queen Queen c3 and rook to b3 now
Queen to d1 and now rook to d8 and Adams
is playing every move what a tempo and
he's really bringing his pieces into the
game they're really coming alive
and here queen the c1 and we to see one
is the only move that is good for
Caruana if he tried something like 934
it seems like okay you're attacking the
rook and if black captures you want
double your pawns
it seems seems like a great idea but
after night to d4
Queen to g5 now and now you're the queen
is attacking d3 pawn the rook as well
your knight is just pinned on before so
not not really any not really something
white would enjoy so after up to d8
Queen to c1 definitely the best move a
for now locking that rock on b3 rock the
c5 rook to d7 inch three now Queen to d8
and g4g six Kings to h1 team to g7e five
Bishop to d5 now King to g1 Bishop back
to e6 King to f2 both layers are now
searching what what the other guy will
play Queen to e7 King to g1 and the rook
to d5 okay rook the c4 attacking the a4
pawn rook to a5 defending and rook to c2
Bishop to d5 again and now Knight to d4
and here Knight captures on d4 was
played by Adams allowing a capture sandy
for on doubling the pawns and this seems
like like a weird choice but if you play
something like rook to b6 to protect the
night because the bishop is also
attacking it after Bishop captures on d6
on d5 rook captures and ecigs black is
actually falling apart you have to
capture the pawn capture and now Knight
captures and c6 the rook captures rook
captures be captors and Queen captures
black is down upon but also with four
pawn islands it's a it's basically a
winning position for white
if played correctly so after night the
d4 Knight capture Sun before was the
lesser evil he capture some d4 and rook
to g3 and this rook to g3 is probably
why Adams went I went for this knife
capture Sun d4
it seems like okay the bishop is pinned
the bishop and rook are attacking the
bishop on g2 and karana has some options
here like playing III so the rockin c2
would be defending the bishop also rook
to f2 is an option but karana finds the
absolute best maneuver and and it's a
very nice maneuver rook to f3
seems like he's given up a rook but
Bishop captures an f3 was played in the
game and here he captures an F through
it was played trapping the rook so this
rock will have to you know sacrifice
itself for the exchange here but an
interesting variation actually arises
here after rook to a3
what if black plays Queen to h4 now to
protect the road then rook captures on
g3 Queen captures and Queen to f1
stopping checkmate on g2 and this is
perfectly fine for white Bishop captures
Queen captures let's say Queen b3
attacking the rook rook captures and c7
ro captures on e5 now you can't capture
the rook or else or you'll get Queen b6
check and you lose the c7 rook but here
simply rook captures on f7 King captors
and D captures on e5 and as you can see
her down to pawns and it's a winning
winning position for white
so after rook to have three Bishop
captures on f3 by Adams eek actress and
now c6 King - H - now the rook must
sacrifice itself rook captures King
captures and rook to d5 rook to c4 again
attacking the a4 pawn c5 now row
captures nc54
row capture son b4 Queen to c3
positioning the Queen to I death King
and g7
Queen to d8 worked the c8 attacking the
Queen Queen b6 and rook to e8
we have g5 rook to e7 now threatening a
sex with tempo King to g8 and now e6 all
together because the Queen can't capture
if you capture with the Queen you lose
it of course so F characters e6 is the
only move
F captures and now Queen to c2 here
karana gave
that porn queen c8 doesn't really do
anything you can simply retreat with the
Queen or with the rook but Queen to c2
actually threatens check mate with the
Queen to h7 check and then followed by
g7 or f7 checkmate
so King to f8 I'm not allowing the Queen
to jump to h7 with tempo Rock to h7 now
and it's a very tricky position here
Adams played Queen to c6 offering a
trade of Queens because if he plays
something like rook to Queen to d6 to
threaten Rudy to for example winning the
Queen this actually loses to a force to
checkmate in 7 moves Rock h8 check King
e7 Queen h7 checking f6 now captures
king f7 Rock check King yet and now
Queen g6 check King d8 and Queen to g8
followed by Queen has the block and the
Queen captures on f8 which weather nice
checkmate
so after rook h7 Adams decided to trade
Queen's Queen captures v captures karana
is happy to trade Queens it's not the
material is equal both players have five
pawns and the rook it's a it's an almost
like an equal rock ending but again
Black has four point islands White has
only two and in rock endings this
matters a lot
plus the King is protecting all the
pawns on the King side and Adam says
Adams sir King is pretty cut off from
the game so rook captures on h6 already
grabbing a pawn can get 7 King g3 rook
to d2 rock h7 check King f6 and rook to
b7 defending the b2 pawn king e5 h 4 now
capture screen captures can get fourth
with a very nice idea of rock to H -
checkmate
so rock to f7 check pushing the King
back King g3 now rook to d1 and in this
position when you realize that even
though capturing the pawn is the best
move you don't really gain anything by
it and by now you realize that you lost
this game rook to d1 g5 now rook checks
a king gauge for a rogue g2 again going
for the pawn but preparing the pawn to
g6
'if I've now point
gee sex rock captures came to g5 checks
engage six checks King to g7 we have c5
king f 7c for the pawn is almost almost
the Queen rook to h7 pinning the pawn
but rock to a6 and in this position
after six hours of playing Michael Adams
resigned to the game what would what
could follow here is simply C 3 let's
say rook captures c2 the rook is now
stopping the pawn and after something
like King the d2 is simply a for this
rook will eventually sacrifice itself
for the pawn but the a5 pawn is
unstoppable and the rook the dark square
the rar crook can protect both the Jeep
on and the 8th one I can't stop it
so let's say Queen C 1 upon 2 c1 Queen
Rock capture screen captures a5 King to
d1 a6 Rock age 6 a 7 rock a6 and g8
Queen rook captures and a queen against
the roof is completely winning but yeah
after rook to a6 Michael Adams the
Englishman resigned the game and Fabiano
Caruana is the winner of the London
chest classic 2017 if you've seen in my
previous video although Corona won the I
mean he is the winner but he has to go
to tie breaks with Nepal Miyaichi
although I'm making this video just at
the moment I saw that Caruana defeated
Nepal me Archie so he is the winner but
I haven't checked all the games that
will see if there is a nice game from
the Thai breaks they were 10-minute
games so if if there was a nice game I
will show one game at least one game
from that Thai break so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank me how sterling and David
what tablet for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon maybe
even with a another alpha0 game